nous partons de saint-hubert à bord d'un
hélicoptère griffon des forces
canadiennes direction sainte marthe de
soul 2011 2017 2019
pour le major saintonge et le capitaine
martin pelletier deux pilotes
d'expérience du 438e escadron tactique
c'est presque devenu leur routine du
printemps allez constater vue du ciel
l'ampleur des dégâts en pesant 190
pendant un mois
4km d'avenue complètement submergé les
mois la digue et pour le jeune auteur
comment une simple rupture de 25 mètres
a pu faire autant de dégâts
[Musique]
pointe-calumet il de carillon au cas
partout la même constatation
l'eau manque de place et reprend sa
place
l'allemagne a raconté inspection aussi
un amant de la rivière rouge du fameux
barrage fragilisé des chutes belle
fragilisée mais qui tient toujours
major cet enjeu le voir du audiences
quand même impressionnant et
l'association cas c'est désolant pour
les citoyens mais on est là pour les
soutenir les aider les rassurer je tiens
en 2007 vous ah oui j'étais présent de
réception nous serons les inondations la
situation est encore pire qu'en 2007
on voit toujours des heures ce soir
c'est décourageant pour la population
mais allez pas armés m'ont toujours être
là pour les soutenir dans le désastre
naturel une semaine n'avait pas vu ça
bien c'est beaucoup la non la situation
instable loue mon poids mais à la 75ème
assez stable au niveau des pôles au
j'allais rester le temps qu'il faut en
fait vous voyez effectivement on va être
là jusqu'au bout pour soutenir la
population ce qui nous vient en tête en
roulant à bord de véhicules de l'armée
dans ses rues inondées
c'est la fureur de l'eau la rapidité
avec laquelle les 6000 résidants ont dû
quitter laissant leur voiture leur bien
et même leurs animaux avec vos
embarcations vous vous le faites la wii
en a 700 matin oui oui on assez couru à
trois chiens oiseaux
les gens doivent être extrêmement
reconnaissants oui sont vraiment
attrayant et apprécie vraiment l'armée
qui viennent convient d'en être avec un
autre
vous avez fait quoi ce matin c'est quoi
l'objectif de la faune n'est venu ici
pour installer des pompes pas à fond
quand la digue a cédé samedi
le cru remonter puis ça a été transféré
de l'autre côté rail la faune pour
empêcher que la zone inondable soit
rempli un affront on aura voté pour
d'autres côtés
c'est plate que s'ils arrivent mais on
est quand même un peu compte à part et
de pouvoir aider à notre manière parce
que s'effondre de ça c'est un peu d'air
saviez-vous loc
vexé l'âge c'est la chose la plus
intense que j'ai vu de ma vie le t shirt
de police les a bougés les avait
vraiment du moment c'était assez
impressionnant
voilà la réaction rapide de tout le
monde c'est quand même très bien la
colonelle marie-christine harvey dirige
les opérations ici l'opération de samedi
soir a été un grand succès je pense
qu'on a beaucoup appris de 2017 quoique
ça c'est bien fait en 2007 des comptes
relève
la grosse différence c'est qu'on a
déployé très tôt en mode préventif
donc cette portion non nous a permis de
faire la coordination dès le début et
d'établir des bonnes relations
alors qu'on n'était pas nécessairement
en état de crise mais on prévoyait une
crise pire d'en créer des relations dans
les étapes
au début dans le fond parce que ça va
être beaucoup pour les relations puis l
entraide samedi soit sainte marthe
savoir restez dans vos souvenirs gravés
à jamais ça ap absolument j'étais avec
le commandant sur place on était en
train d'inspecter un site pour la
filtration d'eau à oka puis il est parti
dit young sanahuja partout puis on à
sentir et aux urgences mais évidemment
on était bien on voulait réagir et des
avec nous les autorités en place
le service des incendies la police ne vu
tout de suite les pompiers circuler ces
routes puis ça a été pris en charge
assez rapidement aucun blessé un miracle
comme le disait le premier ministre pour
militaire ils sont efficaces sont
entraînés sont équipés sont très
opérationnels vie ont la volonté de
servir les gens venaient ici là l
appoint que ces plats indiens
moi je suis par obligation son auto ça
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour aider
qui s'intéressait à tout cela et on est
une star on l'a même aidé sa de l'esg
rouge qu'on peut aller pour aller aider
non on ne construit jamais au fond
est-ce que vous en aviez 500 honnêtement
je pense que pour le moment on est on
est correct on a suffisamment mangé plus
de 1000 personnes au québec
moi aussi que sur les inondations on
serait la tâche si jamais vraiment le
sua janvier les gars en pire et on
verrait de mai pour moi je parle de
suffisamment de gens solidaires et
n'oublions pas les passages non plus on
a les policiers les pompiers qui ont un
travail exceptionnel
les gens des mutualités alors je sais ma
venue rendre les dépenses pour vrai bien
entre les pompiers les policiers
sécurité civile et vous il n'y a pas de
petites compétitions non pas toi moi
j'allais pas vu cash d'arrivée ça me
rassure les vieux j'ai un des premiers
militaires est arrivé sur place ont
établi un poste comme un conjoint et
l'on déléguer des tâches le mot jours
après ce qu on était capable de faire
et là tout s'est bien déroulé
honnêtement là ça s'est vraiment bien
déroulée la mer est se présente sur
place avec nous aussi c'est merveilleux
et maintenant il faut penser à demain
malgré la fatigue et le découragement
nos troupes sont vraiment fatigué ça
fait deux semaines qu'on travaille ce
soir et nuit et jodie juste la
protection de l'ase exposé voyez toutes
les poches qui est sur le banc ça a été
fait il ya deux semaines avec toute mon
équipe les bénévoles de la ville
c'est juste des journaux jusqu'à 200
bénévoles et nous a aidé le ils sont la
pression s'est mis en mouvement grâce
aux bénévoles
on avait sauvé la dic puis quand même et
on célébrait sa santé tout le monde est
découragé la mire venu là on est reparti
de l'avant aujourd'hui enfin en attaque
on a fait une barrière physique
temporaire sur la 29e avenue
on l'a terminé on a mis des ponts là on
n'est pas seulement dépendre on est
décédé ce matin d'attaquer le point bas
de la ville et on sent bien à chacun des
avenues pour vider toutes les réseaux
d'égout pluvial
une fois qu'on a atteint notre niveau
plus bien hormis nos stations de pompage
en fonction et la ville vont commencer à
apparaître
on se donne encore une semaine une
nouvelle ville qui va arriver qui va
sortir de l'eau par la suite j'ai des
camions des routes 56 camion vous dites
les gens puissions le convent sont
fatigués sont à bout et ont besoin de
bras ou si on peut pas imaginer revivre
ça dans un an ou deux j'imagine que vous
auriez même pas y penser
ben je voyais franc avec vous avec le
conseil on avait pris une décision dont
les plans et devis était fait pour
remonter la digue
on avait fait une demande pour faire une
demande pour nice à l'environnement pour
justement autorisé les travaux on pense
qu'on s'envoie j'espère que j'ai le bon
terme 1 entente ministère
l'entente du ministère pourrait léser
travaux donc on était rendu la sicile à
dire de posséder les processus se
faisait piste est un projet de 2.2
millions pour réaliser les travaux puis
ça se faisait sur les deux prochaines
années mais je pense qu'on va revoir
notre kiné je dois m'asseoir et les
conseils je veux pas m'avancer sur rien
mais il ya des travaux qui vont soir et
ça c'est sûr et certain
je vous souhaite bonne chance pour puis
courage pour les gens vous regardent
merci bonne journée